these people are willing to sacrifice
their businesses capabilities to step up
for the greater good and the fact that
these stories are not front-page
everywhere at a time when the American
public is panicked and you could offer
them a sliver of hope is to me not only
dishonest
it is journalistic malpractice when it
comes to the handling of the the Chinese
virus have you heard the media celebrate
any of the innovations made by the
private sector you talking about
retooling your factories for masks for
testing for treatment for therapeutics I
think that it's journalistic malpractice
that these aren't being shouted from the
rooftops right now yeah why don't we
want to give people hope it seemed that
they want to give people false hope in
this idea of Medicare for all our
socialized health care system because of
course this is what we need to talk
about the claim that we're seeing from
the left on the corona virus pandemic is
that we wouldn't have these problems if
we had universal health care the public
sector could make all of us go away
hears them saying it because you don't
have taking my word for it
we will talk I'm sure about Medicare for
all but when I talk about health care
being a human right and all people
having health care the coronavirus
crisis makes that abundantly clear as to
why it should be wrong is the
coronavirus the best case for Medicare
let's reverse that show a virus is a
very good case looking in through the
lens of an aquarium there is no middle
ground when it comes to dealing with a
national security threat and Medicare
for again is an example of a policy that
would take on that threat with the
seriousness that it requires to be taken
on what would Medicare for all do it
would ensure that people actually could
get a test for coronavirus that they
could get treatment for the coronavirus
come come again [ __ ] here's the thing
I don't think we could have a more
crystal clear case that the exact
opposite is true
kovin 19 the Chinese virus wolf flute
whatever you want to call it there has
never been more of a crystallization as
to
the need for private industry due to the
sheer ineptitude of the government they
talk about the corner compares to other
countries this is something that
actually I stumbled across let's take
the countries at the top of the world
health organization their rankings right
they rank this 36 right next to Slovenia
now with it let's take them with a
comparable population size to the United
States let's look at their total deaths
and deaths per capita Italy's number two
and Spain's number seven whoops we
barely edged out Slovenia here's the
government muck this up private industry
is fixing it and they're being held
responsible with fixing it so there are
a few examples that we can walk through
as to why you shouldn't entrust all of
your health all of your health and
health care needs to the government
let's go back to the Obama
administration right they never
replenish the stockpile of masks after
the Ebola scare now I know I know people
can be upset you're gonna blame Donald
Trump for not accepting masks from China
here's the thing the truth is a lot of
these masks and test kits from China
they've had to be recalled
yeah the countries that use them they're
pre infected so they didn't know they
came pre in fact yeah it was the pre
infected version you don't want they
thought it was like a cigar roller when
they test one cigar in every box it like
box of 25 more it's not griefing it's
kind of like those smallpox blankets
same come I already pay shipping so
first what are you talking about if they
got socialized health care everyone will
be able to be tested right guys so let's
be that it couldn't be more dishonest
that is if today we're opposite day like
if we were going into scouts where they
have opposite day and everyone wears
their clothes on backwards because it's
fun and we like to have a laugh he would
be tops but here's another truth for you
at first the CDC was the only place
approved by the FDA to make the testing
kits oh right
the CDC refused testing kits and
capabilities from the private sector and
we all know how that turned out only
once the private sector industry was
allowed to step up and keep this keep in
mind tooth they were already stepping up
but they weren't allowed to did we see
the improvement since then what do we
have we have unites companies have
developed the fasting test fasting
testing kits fastest testing kits in the
world Abbott Laboratories
I have that
yeah I'm at us company they mented a co
vid test five minutes boom you get rid
of only earlier this week and then they
were topped by another company bodies
fear developed a two minute test that
was approved today true is the magic
number two minute Cove it'd testing
stick that your pipe and kill yourself
with its EDC and here's another here's
another problem not learn from the
mistakes the FDA they're still
preventing private companies from
creating as many tests as possible
they're only approving a hundred
thousand a day when these companies
could be upping it to one hundred and
sixty thousand a day the government the
government is not here to help I just
want to make that very clear by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed hit all notifications so
you're notified when everybody goes up
goes up at 9:00 p.m. Eastern of course
mug club quarantine all month $30 off
promo code quarantine and we are doing
morning shows live talking with you at
10:00 a.m. by the way here's something
else just to show you how smug the media
is remember they they mocked Donald
Trump mercilessly when he made this
suggestion just either I think it might
have been earlier this week at the most
last week they're throwing away the
masks right away they're thrown away and
when you hear 55 million masks world I'm
saying 55 million how could it possibly
be such a number and they say oh that's
just a small fraction of what we need
and I said why are we sanitizing masks
you know you look at the mess I've
looked at all the different masks some
don't LED themselves to doing that I
think but many do and I said why aren't
we have very good liquids for doing this
sanitizing the masks and that's
something they're they're starting to do
more and more the sanitizing the masks
okay a couple of things here first off
this was assumed to be crazy was leftist
outlets claiming he would be responsible
why citing federal guidelines because
the federal guidelines would of course
be correct here's a thing we also need
to separate what Donald Trump says from
the sound but you see on Twitter when
you hear that of course in its totality
okay that makes sense he says he even
hedges his words some masks maybe some
masks not but you have to understand the
difference between what Donald Trump
says sometimes what he means well we we
had some very thin liquids of the media
says he just thinks she can spray sand
Everclear on it and call it a day know
what he was talking about with some kind
of a system who make masks reusable
recycling you should be fans of that
right no not one
well careful block your mouth don't let
this tin can I'm about to kick hit you
in the teeth you pieces because Patel a
non-profit started using this mask
sanitization technology they now have
machines that can sanitize 80,000 masks
a day in Ohio are shipping machines to
other states they'll hopefully result in
400,000 masks being cleaned per day so I
get it him say we have verified liquids
okay very fine Idol equates to the best
since babies support whatever it is that
you want to assume he's saying it's not
that crazy every single journalist
should be talking about how now they can
sanitize tens or hundreds of thousands
of masks per day we are going to have
hundreds of thousands new masks made
because of private industry who stepped
up who by the way didn't even have to be
forced to buy the defense production act
approve the drug that Donald Trump was
touting last week that you said was
irresponsible because there was no kind
of medical basis you're wrong you're
wrong and you should be happy that
you're wrong because it's going to save
I mean let's be honest dozens of lives
with this pandemic here going on here's
another claim that they've made quite a
bit that other countries with the
socialized healthcare systems that
they've somehow done better than ISIL at
them but the federal government the
Trump administration watching the
rollout of testing for this virus it
continues to set the United States apart
FTA Financial Times in London today put
out this graph showing how how well
various countries are doing in terms of
testing for the virus when you look at
the best you know that's something
that's up for debate
South Korea we're up to South Korea has
up to 10,000 tests per day they've been
able to provide tests to any single
person that wants it and here people are
scrambling okay alright so the South
Korea let's go back to Bert wards
comments their birth meadow country that
they're talking about who they've
praised for years of course based on the
World Health Organization's ranking
which by the way I love now that no one
can ever use that again The Young Turks
Network the leftist organizations you
can't say when we ranked behind what
France Italy Spain do we really want to
talk about that anymore
we always knew that way the case because
a subjective polling but now you know
it's the case because the entire world
seen it once Italy said you know what
you're over 60 you're on your own and
that's not so old they retire at like 35
in Italy they don't create anything that
benefits the rest of the world pasta was
Chinese piss off really so let's look at
Italy with a nationalized health care
system right they had by far the highest
death rates and his population quite
elderly of course the intensive care
units they were just advised just they
said what do we do with these elderly
people and as well I don't just don't
just don't do anything but what do we do
how do we help them it just don't help
them because we don't we can't I mean we
can't raise taxes anymore and people
don't work yeah but you said we call the
government and the wait time you talked
about this before the wait times are
terrible we've talked about this with
all these countries you can go back and
watch your socialized health care videos
and if you have a broken arm or
something to them it's a nuisance
because it's non-essential like a
nosebleed but now when it comes to a
pandemic there can be no debate there's
no denying that the wait times increase
the mortality rates of that it's and at
the very least it's a violation of Human
Rights to not allow people to purchase
privatized health care which is
increasingly rare in these countries but
that was the case in Canada at least
until 2005 let's go to South Korea by
the way this is one that really bothers
me as people point to South Korea sure
they did they were ahead of us on
testing absolutely because they quickly
mobilized and what do they do they use
the private sector for testing kits
which the CDC here said no no you can't
do now that we're doing it we're
surpassing South Korea very quickly oh
yeah also something that when people
point to South Korea as a successful
example of the social distancing
protocols they effectively doxed their
own citizens yeah so they were tracking
the phones of citizens and then released
detailed information to the public via
apps including age descriptions and
movements over the past few days but
people could say oh I see man have a
sneeze go Tupac we kill him so if we
want to this is something really
important because when they in trying to
demonize the United States because of
the Communists sympathizing media and I
mean that because they were actually
parroting Communist Chinese government
talking points I say it without a hint
of hyperbole hyperbole hype rising
hyperboles hyperbole and I throw a pipe
at the camera there you go 3d show on
TGIF
without a hint of hyperbole this media
who is sympathetic to the Chinese
government they will take any
opportunity to demonize the American
government at all costs well when you
tell them we should we should be like
South Korea let the American public know
what they did Americans you think they
have a greater success rate here in
dealing with Corona okay if you just
want to use them on um one metric but
are you willing to turn over all of your
phone's data there are you willing to
turn over all your location services not
to your private web searching on your
iPhone you want to turn that over to the
government they can release it to the
public because South Korea did I know
you could kill everybody who has this
virus as well and have zero new cases
yes all right all right you do that and
just report hey you're doing fantastic
we killed it's kind of like Russia yeah
right we don't hear anything out of
Russia I guarantee you they have some
they're like I will just kill him that's
what low see to make a cabinet yeah you
don't see them anymore
maybe senior assistant bring her coffee
no no no no no why she needs their souls
to sustain herself so another truth we
weren't as far along as other countries
that's true once we started testing and
we started testing more people in eight
days I think eventually than that South
Korea tested in eight weeks once we
started testing and now of course we
have more privatized industries we
talked about stepping up so we can test
more people again bottleneck CDC
socialized government that's what we're
talking about here right socialized
healthcare run by the government versus
private industry coming out with a five
minute test in a two minute test I bet
you the next one you it'll just you just
start to say the word test into the test
like you're positive yeah just it could
tell by my very terrible test more than
any other country in the world right now
as far as that so that talking point is
gone as well here's another point that
they'll still make another area where
the United States actually by the way is
doing really well because of the private
sector independent researchers they
found success was combination therapy we
don't have a cure but we do have what
they call therapeutics we do have
treatment Donald Trump went up and
talked about chloroquine chloroquine
chloroquine chloroquine chloroquine
chloroquine I don't care fish tank just
go home to South Fidel just take a shot
and tell us how it works out though dill
said he was mocked across the media
right this is you're responsible
well now it's FDA approved
emergency's it was already an
fda-approved drug because of its safety
profile but now it's FDA approved
specifically for coronavirus but before
that a private practitioner had
prescribed an off-label had 699 people
who were treated successfully not to
mention all the independent testing
which we talked about on this channel
and this is really concerning Twitter
and YouTube were removing or censoring
videos that talked about chloroquine as
fake news or talked about Chinese masks
being faulty they've removed some of
these tweets and videos how scary is
that when these people are in charge of
of fact-checking and not only are they
dishonest but they are dishonest in the
way in a way that could save thousands
of lives when we're talking about a
vaccine yes researchers are working on a
vaccine and it'll probably take about a
year and a half
why mostly because of the FDA baggage
just for the same reason it's chloride
it's really hard to move a barge it's
sometimes more helpful when you have
Donald Trump coming in with chloroquine
another bars going get get out of the
way
it's terrible this shows more of a
tugboat it's easier to move so here's
something what we're talking about we do
have to get going with razörfist and
then we'll see you tomorrow for a good
morning mug Club but this is something
that just bothers me so much I don't
think it could possibly be more clear at
this point that we need the private
sector the only other country that's had
success beyond daxing its citizens when
you look at South Korea's because they
did mobilize the private sector once we
started doing that here in the United
States guess what we start doing better
and guess what else Donald Trump start
speaking directly to his audience with
these evening press briefings his
approval rating goes up so what do they
do
let's stop airing Trump let's run a
story about people who drank fish tank
cleaner to condemn Trump for touting a
drug oh wait it's been approved by the
FDA and it actually shows some of the
grassy let's not cover it let's blame
Donald Trump for saying that we should
be able to sanitize mess oh wait a
second we actually can do that now
because private industry stepped up to
do it it's almost like Donald Trump said
this kind of knowing that was coming
around the corner let's just silence
this this is an amazing situation for me
because after 9/11 and I know the LA
girl didn't like George Bush at the very
least we came together for the common
need and right now we're fighting this
sort of invisible enemy I know some
people think it's not technically
invisible keep a microscope I don't care
the point here is that I don't know if
it'll ever be a time now where we'll
come together
again against an enemy if something
could ever help us find common ground
yeah it would be this right here and I
don't just mean fighting a virus but I
mean the idea that we are making
unbelievable headway and we are making
headway not from tearing people away
from their jobs in place of business and
having them holed up in their apartments
though some people need to continue
doing that obviously but we're making
headway because of American businesses
innovating and stepping forward to save
fellow Americans lives I know it's a bad
narrative because one thing that
capitalism is greedy and bad but guess
what these people are willing to
sacrifice their businesses capabilities
to step up for the greater good and the
fact that these stories are not
front-page everywhere at a time when the
American public is panicked and you
could offer them a sliver of hope is to
me not only dishonest
it is journalistic malpractice I don't
even know if that's a real thing because
you're not really held to any kind of
standard like a lawyer or a doctor but
if you could be we hang you up at dawn
before breakfast figuratively speaking
of course not literally none I just want
you fired and on the unemployment line
with everyone else will you've harmed if
you enjoy this video click this box
because you'll enjoy Gerald show that he
hosts I'm kidding just subscribe and hit
the notification bell hit all
notification boxes to up here click one
of these videos if you injure them so
subscribe notification bell think about
joining mug club atlético Tom slash mug
club and Gerald a so you need to know